[Applaudissements]
celui qu'on appelle la locomotive de
sainte-julie entre en gare
charles hamelin couronne une immense
carrière devant sa foule sa famille et
s'offre un dernier tour de piste avec sa
fille je la voulais cette heure-là pire
juste de l'avoir eue avec moi de l'avoir
dans le plus voir un peu c'est quoi ma
vision d'être la chose sans la glace
même ça n'a pas conscience de ce qu'est
ce qui s'est passé a encore plus beaux
souvenirs de sa vie en euros plein de
photos est monté de la dame à court de
papa qui via l'aide soit le pouvant son
papa c'est juste la plus belle chose au
monde sait ce qu'ils voulaient pis ça
s'est réalisé au huitième fois rien
[Musique]
un champion olympique met un point
d'orgue à son aventure sportive en
décrochant un 38e podium le bronze au
relais masculin
un dernier succès dont il a savouré
chaque seconde et qui s'ajoute aux 150
médaille de coupe du monde et aussi ce
podium olympique le palmarès est
exceptionnel mais pour charles hamelin
le plaisir à prix mais surtout je suis
fier de cette viande
de tout l'acharnement que j'ai eu le
plaisir que j'ai eu à faire cet
acharnement le puits j'ai expliqué
beaucoup dans ma carrière j'ai eu mal
aux jambes beaucoup j'ai aimé avons mal
aux jambes sera plus le
même si ça fait toujours mal mais j'ai
aimé avoir mal charles hamelin passe le
flambeau à une équipe canadienne
bourrique talent qui a remporté huit
médailles à ses derniers mondiaux et qui
compte désormais deux vice champions du
monde qui aime boutin et pascal d'ions
deux athlètes inspiré le travail à
l'entraînement le travail dans les
compétitions c'est ce qui fait qu'il ya
été un champion puis je pense que on a
tellement revenir de ce salon un idole
qui est réellement si cette personne
mais qui m'a permis de croire en ce que
je voulais réaliser à écrire écrire ma
propre histoire
celui qui aura bientôt 38 ans quitte
lamentait et avec la tête pleine de
projets et se marie en juin et compte
partager son amour pour le patin avec
les plus jeunes ce qui s'en vient c'est
superbe aussi cuit alors vous le voyez
l'intelligent clause est ce pire c'est
juste bon à sa fiche vraiment fier de
charles de tous cas qu'on
a mené aura inspiré toute une génération
de patineurs et ce n'est pas terminé
et si diane survie radio-canada à
montréal